Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur 36. Ausgabe unserer kleinen Gesprächsreihe, die sich um die Raumfahrt dreht und auch um viele Themen drum herum. Heute allerdings gehen wir mal wieder mitten ins Herz und berichten von einem sehr wichtigen Teil der Raumfahrt, der hier auch in vielen vorherigen Gesprächen schon auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise angesprochen worden ist. Heute soll er einmal im Mittelpunkt stehen. Es geht um das Deutsche Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum oder auch German Space Operations Center, kurz GSOC genannt. In Oberpfaffenhofen befinde ich mich heute. Tatsächlich gehört zu dieser ganzen Unternehmung aber auch noch einiges mehr. Und darüber wollen wir heute sprechen und zwar mit Florian Sellmeier.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, du bist hier am Standort Oberpfaffenhofen fest installiert. Und das Ganze ist im Institut für Raumflugbetrieb und Astronautentraining angesiedelt. Was ist denn hier so deine Kernaufgabe, um die du dich hier so zu kümmern hast?
Ja, hier am Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum leite ich die Geschäftsfeldentwicklung. Das heißt, wir sind in einem Team mit insgesamt sieben Mitarbeitern am Standort in Oberpfaffenhofen und in Köln verantwortlich dafür, dass wir neue Missionen bekommen, die wir später betreuen und fliegen. Das heißt, die Raumfahrt allgemein ist eine sehr langfristige Geschichte. Wenn jetzt heute eine Mission fliegt, dann gab es vor sieben Jahren oder vor zehn Jahren mal jemand, der sich darum gekümmert hat, dass die Mission überhaupt finanziert wird, dass die Ideen dann umgesetzt werden, in Studien zunächst und später dann im Design und dann irgendwann wird ein Satellit gestartet und von uns betrieben und betreut.
Das heißt, das Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum, wie der Name ja auch schon ein bisschen sagt, das ist dann der Teil, der sich eben aktiv um die Durchführung der Projekte kümmert, wenn die Dinge dann erst mal oben sind bzw. auch, um sie erst mal nach oben zu bekommen.
Ja, wenn die Satelliten oben sind oder die Astronauten oben sind, sind wir diejenigen, die uns die Mission betreiben. Also beim Satelliten fliegen wir die Satelliten, wir sind sozusagen die Piloten der Satelliten, die eigentlich bemannt sind. In der Anfangsphase der Treiber ist in der Regel das Raumsegment. Vielleicht kann ich ganz kurz jetzt mal das benutzen, um das ein bisschen einzuordnen. Also die Raumfahrt besteht in der Regel aus drei Segmenten, das ist das Raumsegment, das sind also in der Regel die Industrie, die sich darum kümmert, einen Satelliten zu bauen oder ein Modul von der Raumstation zu bauen. Die Industriepartner suchen dann in der Regel einen Launcher, also das sogenannte Startsegment, also auf Deutsch einfach eine Rakete, die den Satelliten nach oben bringt. Und das dritte Segment ist dann das Bodensegment, das ist das Segment, was den Satelliten oder die Mission dann nach dem Start betreibt. Und das ist genau unsere Aufgabe. Zum Bodensegment gehört einmal der Missionsbetrieb, das sind also die Leute, die im Kontrollraum sitzen und an den Konsolen sitzen und die Satelliten steuern. Und zum Zweiten die Kommunikationsarchitektur, die Antennen, mit welchen wir mit den Satelliten kommunizieren und kommandieren können. Das ist so grob die Aufgabe des GSOCs, des Deutschen Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrums, verantwortlich für das Bodensegment zu sein.
Wobei da ja auch mit anderen Organisationen und Instituten wiederum zusammengearbeitet wird, wie den Bodenstationsnetzwerken, die weltweit die ganzen Antennen betreiben, etc.
Richtig.
Das hatten wir ja hier auch schon mal bei Raumzeit-Ausgabe 28 von der ESA, das Estrec-Bodenstationsnetzwerk, das ist halt eins dieser Systeme, mit denen zusammengearbeitet wird.
Ganz genau. Also wir haben eine eigene Bodenstation am Standort in Weilheim und gleichzeitig benutzen wir andere Bodenstationen in einem weltweiten Netzwerk, die zu anderen Kontrollzentren gehören. Die wiederum benutzen unsere Bodenstationen für ihr Netzwerk. Also das ist ein Geben und Nehmen auf der Seite der Bodenstationen.
Ist die Station in Weilheim in irgendein anderes Netzwerk jetzt eingebunden oder steht die für sich?
Die Station in Weilheim ist unsere DLR-Bodenstation mit einer ganzen Reihe von Antennen. Eine 30 Meter Antenne, eine 15 Meter Antenne, eine 13 Meter Antenne und so weiter. Die aber in einem Center of Networks zum Beispiel mit eingebunden ist. Also das ESOC in Darmstadt und CNES in Toulouse benutzt unsere Bodenstationen zu besonderen Konditionen. Und umgekehrt können wir deren Bodenstationen auch zu besonderen Konditionen verwenden. Darüber hinaus haben wir aber jetzt gerade was die Bodenstation betrifft Partnerschaften und Verträge mit einer ganzen Reihe von Bodenstations-Providern weltweit.
Weil die brauchen wir ja auch, denn die, das Lieden klingen ja überall lang und nicht nur über Deutschland. Genau, schön wär's. Das heißt also Weilheim ist integraler Bestandteil vom GSOC, wenn auch an einem anderen Standort.
Richtig, ganz bewusst an einem anderen Standort gewählt. Weil für den Empfang der Radiodaten ist es günstig, etwas weiter weg von München entfernt zu sein und da bessere Konditionen zu haben.
Von Platz her jetzt?
Oder von der Strahlungsverseuchung. Also ein wichtiger Punkt, die Strahlung, die durch Radiostationen usw. ausgesandt wird, würde dann den Empfang stören mit unseren doch sehr feinen Antennen.
Also man muss dazu sagen, Weilheim ist auch in der Region München angesiedelt, ist nicht so weit weg von hier, aber nicht direkt am selben Standort.
Richtig.
Was gehört noch dazu zum GSOC? Gibt es noch einen weiteren Standort?
Das ist der Hauptstandort hier in Oberpfaffenhofen. Dort befinden sich unsere Hauptkontrollräume. Wir haben also vier große Kontrollräume. Zwei davon sind für den Betrieb des Columbus-Moduls auf der Internationalen Raumstation. Die anderen beiden großen Kontrollräume sind Leop-Kontrollräume, d.h. Launch- und Early-Orbit-Phase-Kontrollräume, die in der Anfangsphase nach dem Start eines Satelliten dafür verwendet werden, den neuen, neugeborenen Satelliten intensiv zu betreiben. Ich vergleiche das deswegen immer mit einer Intensivstation für neugeborene Satelliten, diese großen Kontrollräume. Dann haben wir im Standort Oberpfaffenhofen im anderen Gebäudeteil noch diverse Routine-Kontrollräume, die nach der Anfangsphase verwendet werden, um Satelliten langfristig 15 Jahre lang oder länger zu betreiben. Des Weiteren haben wir eine Testhalle, in der unsere sogenannte EPOS-Halle untergebracht ist, European Proximity Operations Simulator. Das sind zwei große Roboter, mit denen wir rendezvous und docking von Satelliten testen können.
Die ist auch hier am Standort?
Das ist auch hier am Standort in Oberpfaffenhofen. Dann sind im ersten Stock unsere Serverräume, Rechnerräume. Das ist ein Herzstück des Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrums. So wie die ganzen Büroräume für die Mitarbeiter, die sich vorbereiten für die Arbeit im Kontrollraum.
Aber es gibt auch noch einen anderen Standort in Köln?
Den sollte ich auch noch erwähnen. In Köln ist ein Teil des Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrums, und zwar des Länder-Kontrollzentrums, das die Landung des vielen Landes der Mission Rosetta steuern soll.
Ah ja, okay, das ist sozusagen nochmal ganz speziell auf eine bestimmte Mission hin optimiert der Ort. Richtig. Rosetta, eine sehr interessante Mission, die wir auch hier schon besprochen haben. In Ausgabe 20 ein Gespräch mit Gerhard Schweben, wo es sehr detailliert um Rosetta, aber auch um die Mission davor, Giotto, die ja viel damit zu tun hat, ging. Ein spannendes Gespräch kann ich eben nur empfehlen, der da noch nicht reingehört hat. Bevor wir jetzt vielleicht mal so ein bisschen mehr in die Details nochmal vom GSOC reinkommen, wird mich nochmal interessieren, wie so dein eigener Weg hierher so gewesen ist. Geschäftsfeldentwicklung, das klingt so ein bisschen weit ab vom wissenschaftlichen Betrieb. Ich meine, wir werden ja sicherlich noch dazu kommen, auch dass das ja hier auch wirklich insofern ein besonderer Bereich ist, als dass man ja hier nach innen wie außen auch als Dienstleister auftritt und nicht so die kernwissenschaftliche Tätigkeit, wie sie sich jetzt bei der Missionsplanung etc. abspielt, durchführt. Aber wie ist so dein eigener Werdegang gewesen? Bist du auch einer von den Mondlandungsopfern, die da nichts anderes tun konnten?
Nein, ich habe einen Kreis gedreht, sagen wir mal so. Ich bin Astrophysiker, habe in München studiert an dem Institut für Astronomie und Astrophysik und habe dort in dem Gebiet auch promoviert über Spektroskopie von heißen Sternen, also theoretische Astrophysik. An der LMU, ja. Mit kurzem Auslandsaufenthalten in Kalifornien. Habe dann aber nach der Promotion für mich beschlossen, ich möchte in die Industrie gehen und verschiedene Dinge auch noch kennenlernen. Nachdem ich segel schon seit meiner Jugend, habe ich in Starnberg eine Firma gefunden, die Navigationssysteme für Jachten macht und habe dort eine ganz kleine Sechs-Mann-Firma Software entwickelt für PC-basierte Radarsysteme. Ich war dort drei Jahre und dann wurde mir das zu chaotisch in so einer Sechs-Mann-Firma, wo wir eigentlich zu dritt die ganze Programmierung gemacht haben. Ich bin dann in einem großen Unternehmen gelandet. In München gibt es da wenige ganz große. Ich war dann bei Siemens für sieben Jahre. Ich habe dort dann E-Business gemacht und Rechenzentrumsbetrieb. Ich habe nach einer Weile dort das Kompetenzzentrum für E-Business, also eine Fachgruppe, geleitet. Ich bin dann aber in das Consulting, war dann für drei Jahre bei Siemens Unternehmensberater. Und habe von dort aus relativ viele Projekte gemanagt und auch Angebote mit unterstützt für Industrieangebote. Im Jahr 2005 gab es eine Pressemitteilung, dass das Galileo-Kontrollzentrum hier gebaut wird. Ich habe dann innerhalb von zwei Wochen meine Bewerbungsmatte zusammen gehabt und hier ans DLR geschickt. Und bin dann 2006 in einen Raumflugbetrieb gekommen. Ich konnte eigentlich bei jeder Station was mitnehmen für die nächste Station. Ich habe Angebotsmanagement und industrielles Vorgehen in dem Umfeld hier mit reingebracht. Ich hatte aber auch die wissenschaftliche Seite aus der Astrophysik.
Und die ist auch wichtig, oder?
Die ist auch wichtig, dass man beides hat. Man muss ja die Leute auch verstehen, die Interesse haben, Raumflugmissionen zu fliegen. Das sind ganz verschiedene Leute, muss man übrigens sagen. Also es gibt die Wissenschaftler, die Erdbeobachtung machen möchten und die ihre Daten haben möchten. Zum Beispiel von einer Kreismission, Erdschwerefeld, hochgenaue Erdschwerefeldbestimmung. Oder die Aufnahmen machen möchten, die Geowissenschaftler auf der einen Seite. Auf der anderen Seite hat man Grundlagenwissenschaftler, die auf der Internationalen Raumstation ihre Experimente machen zum Thema Schwerelosigkeit. Die möchten irgendwelche elementären Kräfte oder biologische Effekte unter Schwerelosigkeit erforschen. Das ist so das eine Spektrum. Dann hat man aber auch mit den Kommunikationssatelliten, die im geostationären Orbit fliegen, wirklich knallharte Geschäftsleute, die Kommunikationsservices verkaufen wollen. Das ist auch ein Kreis von Leuten, die man verstehen muss und mit denen sprechen können muss.
Und da hilft dann wiederum die Erfahrung aus der Industriezeit.
Und natürlich haben wir unsere Partner in der Industrie, also im Raumsegment, die dann die Satelliten bauen, die industrielles Vorgehen haben.
Das klingt eigentlich nach einem sehr abwechslungsreichen Aufgabenfeld.
Das ist es, das kann man wirklich sagen.
Bleiben wir doch vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz bei dieser Geschäftsfeldentwicklung. Komischer Begriff, aber es ist ja klar, ich habe das auch schon angesprochen, so das Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum. Auf der einen Seite sitzen sozusagen die Piloten für die unbemannten Satelliten bzw. die Ansprechpartner für die bemannten Missionen. Man ist natürlich Dienstleister für diese konkreten Missionen, aber es geht ja auch dann darüber hinaus. Du hast ja jetzt im Prinzip schon mal angesprochen, unterschiedliche Gruppen haben hier Kontakt. Wie ist so das Verhältnis des GSOCs einerseits zum DLR und zu anderen? Wie autark agiert dieses GSOC? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Ja, das GSOC, das Deutsche Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum, ist ein Teil des Instituts für Raumflugbetrieb und Astronautenraining, aber der größte Teil, also der größte Bereich. Das ist die Institute, das DLR hat etwa, da muss ich gerade mal spicken, da steht es nicht drauf, aber etwa 30 Institute in Deutschland verteilt. Der Raumflugbetrieb ist eines von diesen Instituten und die Institute sind doch durchaus autark geführt. Man kann fast sagen, wie eine kleine mittelständische Firma sind wir. Das Institut ist natürlich in dem Rahmen des DLRs eingebettet, was absolut Vorteile hat natürlich. Aber das Institut macht natürlich eine Ergebnisplanung am Ende jedes Jahres. Also es gibt eine gewisse Autonomie, was die Missionen betrifft. Es sind natürlich programmatisch im DLR eingebunden. Es gibt also eine Programmatik und es gibt den Raumfahrtvorstand, der richtungsweisend natürlich ist, was die Raumfahrt betrifft.
Und in welche Felder stößt man jetzt vor? Also ein paar Sachen hast du ja schon angesprochen. Vielleicht kann man mal ein paar gute Beispiele... Ich meine sowas wie, wofür das GSOC ja auch bekannt ist, haben wir ja schon gesagt, hier wird unter anderem die Columbus-Mission, also das eine Columbus-Modul auf der ISS, im Wesentlichen betreut. Das ist natürlich eine Daueraufgabe, die auch lange noch laufen wird.
Also unsere Hauptfelder sind, umreißt die mal kurz, und zwar von unten nach oben. Niedrigsten ist die internationale Raumstation, ISS, und dort betreuen wir das Columbus-Modul. Die ISS fliegt in der Höhe von etwa 350 Kilometer, wobei die Höhe sich permanent ändert. Die muss also angehoben werden und senkt sich dann automatisch ab. Aber so in etwa 350 Kilometer fliegt die in knapp 90 Minuten um die Erde. Und der Betrieb des Columbus-Moduls wird bei uns betreut. Das zweite Feld sind die Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten, die z.B. TerraSat in der Höhe von etwa 500 Kilometer fliegen, also nach wie vor im niedrigen Erdorbit, Low Earth Orbit, LEO genannt. Da fliegen wir eine ganze Flotte von Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten und steuern die von unseren Kontrollräumen aus. Die dritte Klasse von Satelliten sind die Navigations-Satelliten. Galileo ist das europäische Navigationssystem, was jetzt derzeit ja gerade implementiert wird. Das Galileo-Kontrollzentrum ist ursprünglich als Abteilung aus dem Deutschen Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum entstanden. Inzwischen wurde es ausgegründet in eine GmbH und ist jetzt im Nachbargebäude zum GSOC in Betrieb bereits. Also die ersten beiden Navigations-Satelliten werden dort schon operativ geflogen. Die Navigations-Satelliten fliegen im mittleren Erdorbit, MEO genannt, in etwa 23.000 Kilometer Höhe. Dann gibt es die vierte Klasse von Satelliten, die wir betreuen. Das sind die Kommunikations-Satelliten. Die sind aus bestimmten Gründen in einem geostationären Orbit in etwa 36.000 Kilometer Höhe, also noch mal eine Stufe höher. Sie sind in einem sogenannten geostationären Orbit, weil die Dauer auf dieser Umlaufbahn genau 24 Stunden ist.
Also synchron zur Erdrotation und damit immer über derselben Stelle schwiebend.
Ganz genau. Das ist natürlich für einen Fernsehsatelliten, der europäisches Programm ausstrahlen soll, günstig, wenn er immer über Europa steht und nicht einmal über Europa, dann über China, dann über USA und so weiter.
Genau, für einen Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten wiederum wäre es ziemlich langweilig.
Für den wäre es langweilig und der wäre auch zu weit weg. Das sind unsere vier Hauptfelder.
Wie viele Missionen sind das dann, die hier so gleichzeitig betreut werden, um mal so einen Überblick zu kriegen?
Also wir haben jetzt bisher, seitdem das Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum existiert, das ist seit 1968, haben wir knapp 60 oder vielleicht sogar schon über 60 Missionen geflogen. Viele davon nur kurzzeitig in der Anfangsphase, manche aber auch dauerhaft im Regelflugbetrieb. Und momentan haben wir neun Missionen im Regelflugbetrieb, vorwiegend Erdbeobachtungsmissionen sind das, und fünf Missionen im Backup zu einem Regelflugbetrieb, den ein Industriepartner macht.
Was heißt das dann im Backup? Man springt nur ein, falls ein anderes Kontrollzentrum es nicht mehr machen kann?
Also das Deutsche Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum ist ja eine nationale Einrichtung, keine kommerzielle Einrichtung. Das heißt, wir fliegen hauptsächlich nationale Missionen, also Missionen im nationalen Interesse, also wissenschaftliche Missionen oder sicherheitsrelevanten Missionen für die Bundeswehr. Es gibt aber doch eine ganze Reihe von kommerziellen Missionen, die werden dann von einem kommerziellen Kontrollzentrum geflogen. Und diese Partner nehmen uns dann gerne als Backup-Kontrollzentrum, falls sie ein Problem haben in ihrem kommerziellen Kontrollzentrum, können sie schnell umschalten oder mehr oder weniger schnell auf ein Backup-Kontrollzentrum.
Ist das auch schon mal passiert oder ist das immer nur so Theorie geblieben?
Das wird immer wieder aus Testgründen und Trainingsgründen gemacht.
Aber der Ernstfall ist noch gar nicht eingetreten?
Also wir haben intern natürlich auch diverse Backup-Kontrollzentren. Also wir haben hier im Gebäude, Beispiel Columbus, einen Kontrollraum. Daneben ist der erste Backup-Kontrollraum.
Also das ist eigentlich der identische Raum direkt daneben noch mal.
Genau, das ist jetzt Beispiel Columbus. Dann haben wir einen zweiten Backup-Kontrollraum im Nachbargebäude, Nummer 133.
Also dort könnte sich der Erste ausfallen oder sonst irgendein Problem dort existieren. Dann könnte man in den zweiten gehen und wenn da irgendwie der Motor nicht läuft, dann geht man weiter.
Ganz einfaches Beispiel, es geht hier ein Feueralarm los, weil die Suppe auf dem Herd zu stark dampft und der Feuermelder zu sensibel eingestellt ist. Dann muss hier evakuiert werden und auch die Leute aus dem Kontrollraum. Die müssen dann in ein anderes Gebäude gehen.
Dann geht natürlich auch der Backup-Raum nicht.
Dann geht auch der nicht. Aber dafür haben wir im Nebengebäude einen Kontrollraum.
Und der ist auch exakt genauso ausgestattet.
Er ist etwas puristischer ausgestattet, aber er ist so ausgestattet, dass man den kompletten Betrieb dort machen kann. Das ist der zweite Backup. Falls aber der komplette Standort zu schaden gekommen ist, weil zum Beispiel alle Kabel hier ums Gelände irgendwie durchtrennt sind. Oder warum auch immer. Man muss dazu sagen, hier ist alles auch am Standort alles redundant. Wir haben eine redundante Internetanbindung, wir haben eine redundante Stromversorgung usw. Es sind auch redundante Stromnetze, die hier den Standort bespeisen.
Gibt es auch eine eigene Stromversorgung?
Wir haben auch natürlich ein Notstromaggregat, Dieselaggregate, die dann anspringen, falls beide Anschlüsse ausfallen sollten. Räder und Dans ist eines der wichtigsten Themen in der Raumfahrt.
Und auch vor allem hier.
Genau. Ich war jetzt gerade beim Kontrollraum. Falls hier am Standort der zweite Backup-Kontrollraum ausfallen könnte, dann würde das ganze Team nach Weilheim fahren. Dort ist nochmal eine Backup-Möglichkeit.
Sodass man in einer halben Stunde schon wieder operationsfähig sein könnte.
Und falls komplett Deutschland keinen Betrieb mehr machen kann, hat die NASA auch noch eine Möglichkeit, einen ganz limitierten Notfallbetrieb für das Columbus-Modul durchzuführen.
Verstehe. Wobei das Columbus-Modul ja selber wiederum Teil der ISS ist. Also selbst wenn man es nicht weiter betreiben kann, fällt es ja nicht gleich vom Himmel. Sondern es ist ja sozusagen nochmal eingebettet in die Gesamtmission. Wird der selber Aufwand jetzt auch für alle anderen Missionen gemacht? Oder betrifft das jetzt wirklich nur Columbus?
Also der Aufwand bei der bemannten Raumfahrt ist ein Stück höher noch als bei der unbemannten Raumfahrt. Bei der unbemannten Raumfahrt ist einfache Relundanz immer vorgeschrieben. Also wenn eine Stromversorgung ausfällt, brauche ich eine zweite. Das heißt, ich muss noch alle Funktionen durchführen können, wenn ein Teil ausfällt. Bei der bemannten Raumfahrt muss ich noch alle Funktionen ausführen können, wenn zwei Teile gleichzeitig ausfallen. Das heißt, eine Stufe mehr.
Eine Stufe mehr, klar. Dann geht es ja auch um Menschen. Schauen wir doch vielleicht mal konkret auf diese Columbus-Mission, weil das hier viel Raum einnimmt. Einerseits inhaltlich, andererseits auch konkret von den Räumen. Es gibt hier eben dieses Kontrollzentrum. Ich bin eben gerade noch einmal durchgelaufen. Da hat man eine schöne Besucherbrücke, wo man dann wunderbar von oben in diese Räume rausschauen kann. Da kriegt man auch so dieses richtige Raumfahrtgefühl. Viele Bildschirme, viele Leute, die geschäftig an ihren Tastaturen sitzen. Keine auffallende Hektik oder so. Alles geht ganz gemütlich seinen Gang. Beim Start sieht das natürlich ein bisschen anders aus, aber auch da habe ich eigentlich immer, wenn irgendwas wichtiges war bisher, immer sehr konzentrierte Menschen gesehen, die nicht übertreiben. Was muss man denn hier organisieren für das Columbus-Modul? Was ist denn erforderlich? Was muss konkret getan werden, damit da oben der Betrieb flüssig vonstattengehen kann?
Also für die ISS gibt es ja eine ganze Reihe von Kontrollzentren, hast du ja schon vorher erwähnt. Also es gibt in Newston ein Kontrollzentrum für die ISS und in Moskau, also die beiden Hauptkontrollzentren, die die ISS steuern. Dann gibt es aber über Europa, also in Madrid und in Japan und an anderen Stellen noch andere Kontrollzentren, die alle Teile auf der ISS kontrollieren und steuern und Oberpfaffenhofen ist davon eines. Unsere Aufgabe hier ist es zweierlei. Einmal sind wir verantwortlich für das Columbus-Modul als System. Wenn dort irgendein Notfall auftritt, ein Leck oder ein Feuer ausbricht, dann sind wir dafür verantwortlich, das zu überwachen. Also ein Leck- und Feuerüberwachung, Stromüberwachung, Luftzusammensetzungsüberwachung usw. Wir müssen sie mal 24 Stunden permanent überwachen, ob da irgendein Problem auftritt. Man hat diese Überwachung also an den Boden delegiert, damit sich die Astronauten dort oben auf ihre Aufgaben konzentrieren können und bei einer Raumstation in der Größe der ISS, die ja von der Fläche her so groß ist wie ein Fußballfeld, muss man sich das vorstellen, da werden auch die Astronauten überfordert, permanent jede Stelle auf der Raumstation zu überwachen. Das heißt also diese Sicherheitsüberwachung hat man an den Boden delegiert. Das ist eine der Hauptaufgaben. Dann sind wir natürlich im Bereich System auch zuständig für Überwachung der richtigen Stromversorgung, der Temperatur dort, der Schnittstellen zur Raumstation selber, also Wasser und so weiter. Und das sind so im Groben die Bereiche des Systems. Zweite Aufgabe oder weitere Aufgabe ist die Koordinierung der Experimente, die auf dem Columbus-Modul durchgeführt werden. Das Columbus-Modul ist ja nichts anderes als ein Labor unter Weltraumbedingungen. Und da gibt es Leute, die dort Experimente durchführen wollen. Und diese Durchführung der Experimente muss koordiniert werden. Und das sind wir der Knoten. Und zum Weiteren sind wir zuständig für die Datenspeicherung und die Übertragung der Daten. Also das Datenmanagement an Bord des Columbus-Moduls.
Also die Daten, die jetzt vor allem bei den Experimenten entstehen.
Die bei den Experimenten entstehen und dafür, dass die Daten dann auch runtergebracht werden am Boden.
Das heißt, hier wird auch so der eigentliche Einsatzplan durchgezogen. So dieses, was muss eigentlich konkret getan werden? An welchen Experimenten wird gearbeitet? Von wann bis wann etc.?
Genau, also die Missionsplanung ist auch Teil des Columbus-Teams. Man achtet an Langzeitplanung, Mittelzeitplanung, Kortzeitplanung und Umplanung. Falls irgendwas Unvorhergesehenes kommt oder irgendwas länger dauert, dann muss natürlich auch schnell umgeplant werden.
Das heißt, die Astronauten sind eigentlich oben komplett fernbedient? Kann man fast sagen.
Kann man nicht ganz sagen. Also die Astronauten haben natürlich ihre Freiheiten, aber sie sind eingeteilt. Sie haben also den Zeitplan wie in der Schule, also einen Stundenplan, der von Montag bis Freitag jeden Tag sehr genau taktet für die Astronauten. Also die haben Zeiten, wenn sie schlafen können, dann haben sie Post-Sleep-Zeiten, wo sie Zähne putzen und frühstücken und so weiter. Das ist meistens, was genau da passiert ist, unsichtbar für Operator. Dann haben sie Blöcke, wo sie arbeiten, wie ganz normal, 10 Stunden Arbeitstag, von Montag bis Freitag, Mittagessen natürlich. Und dann gibt es Pre-Sleep-Phase wieder vor dem Schlafen. Und dann gibt es eben die Zeit, wo sie schlafen. Man ist dazu übergegangen, kann ich vielleicht mal erwähnen, dass oben nicht im Schichtbetrieb gearbeitet wird, sondern dass die Astronauten, die dort oben sind, alle gleichzeitig, oder mehr oder weniger alle gleichzeitig aufstehen, arbeiten, Mittagessen, wieder arbeiten und dann Abendessen und ins Bett gehen. Man ist dazu übergegangen, heißt das war mal nicht so? Ganz früher gab es Überlegungen, das war tatsächlich vor meiner Zeit, als ich hier war, dass man da im Schichtbetrieb gearbeitet hat. Das war aber nicht so gut für die Psyche der Astronauten.
Weil man keine gemeinsame Freizeit hatte etc.
Genau, und dann hat man auch festgestellt, dass es gar nicht notwendig ist, weil diese grundlegende Überwachung macht man eh besser vom Boden aus. Und wenn dann irgendwas passiert, gibt es Möglichkeiten, die Astronauten zu wecken.
So, jetzt hatten wir die Systemüberwachung, die hatten die wissenschaftlichen Experimente.
Zu den Experimenten sollten wir nochmal sagen, die sind die Experimentatoren, sind zum Teil in sogenannten USOCs zusammengefasst, also User Support Operations Center, wo aus sie die Experimente steuern können. Zum Teil haben sie aber auch eigene Möglichkeiten, die Experimente von ihren Universitäten oder wo auch immer sie sitzen, die zu steuern. Die Steuerung der Experimente geht aber dann immer über den Knoten hier am GSOC. Das heißt, wir sind dafür auch verantwortlich, dass nicht alle Experimentatoren gleichzeitig irgendwie Strom einschalten oder auf bestimmte Ressourcen zugreifen, die dann zusammenbrechen könnten. Das heißt, wir überwachen dann die Vergabe der Ressourcen-Envaloaps, nennt man das, also zugeteilte Ressourcen wie Strom, Astronautenzeit und so weiter und so fort.
Was ist da die Normalität, dass die Wissenschaftler sich an ein solches User-Space-Operation-Center anschließen?
Also User-Support-Operation-Center. Das weiß ich gar nicht, wie die Verhältnisse sind.
Aber es gibt einige solche UsoCs.
Es gibt ein UsoC, das sogenannte MUSC, ist auch Teil des Raumflugbetriebs, das sitzt auch in Köln. Es gibt aber auch andere UsoCs, die in Europa noch verteilt sind. MUSC ist für Micro-Gravity-User-Support-Center.
Das heißt, wenn man ein Experiment hat, was in so ein bestimmtes technisches Feld hineinfällt, dann ist man in der Regel dort angeschlossen. Aber Sachen, die jetzt komplett außerhalb der Regel sind oder andere Anforderungen haben, oder wo man je viel Erfahrung hat mit den Universitäten, oder wo die Universität vielleicht auch selber leitet.
Ja, wobei ich jetzt nicht im Detail auskenne, wie da die Verteilung ist.
Gut, aber es ist halt mal so und es ist mal so. Aber wie auch immer es an der Stelle organisiert ist, alles muss hier erstmal durch das GSOC durchgehen, weil es kann nicht einfach irgendjemand irgendwo was einschalten, ohne dass hier jemand sagt, ja, okay, maletwegen, das darf jetzt auch so sein.
Richtig.
Das heißt, man hat dann auch entsprechend wiederum redundante Leitungen dann auch zu diesen USOCs und so weiter. Wie viele Experimente finden da so gleichzeitig statt? Also jetzt im Columbus-Modul, wie viele Experimente müssen da, gleichzeitig vielleicht die falsche Frage, aber wie ist sozusagen die Gesamtmenge der Experimente, die dort vor Ort betreut werden müssen?
Also es gibt verschiedene Labore dort oben. Es gibt ein Bio-Lab dort oben, also die untersuchen wie zum Beispiel, also als erstes muss man vielleicht noch vorausschicken, ist das Besondere an dem Columbus-Labor ist, dass es ein Labor ist unter Schwerelosigkeit. Und die Schwerkraft ist die einzige physikalische Kraft, die sie am Boden, die sie nicht abschirmen können. Das heißt, sie werden auf der Erde nie die Möglichkeit haben, langfristig Schwerelosigkeit zu haben. Die einzige Möglichkeit ist, kurzfristig eine Schwerelosigkeit zu haben, ist in einem Pfeilturm für ein paar Sekunden oder mit Parabeflügen für wiederholte Sequenzen von ein paar Sekunden. Das heißt, das ist der Sinn und Zweck von dem Columbus-Labor, dass man dort oben Bedingungen unter Schwerelosigkeit hat. Und dann kann man alle möglichen Grundlagen oder Technologieentwicklungsforschungen dort oben durchführen. Und deswegen hat man dann einen ganzen Blumenstrauß an Forschungen dort oben. Biologische Forschung habe ich schon erwähnt. Da möchte man zum Beispiel untersuchen, woher wissen die Pflanzen, was oben und unten ist. Haben die einen Schwerkraftsensor? Das kann man natürlich am besten untersuchen, wenn ich mal die Schwerkraft abschnell stelle und schaue, wie wachsen die Pflanzen. Man findet dann zum Beispiel, dass die Wurzeln in spiralenförmig wachsen. Das ist eine Art, die man dort oben untersuchen kann. Dann gibt es das Plasmaphysik, zum Beispiel bestimmte Kräfte und Wechselwirkungen, die sehr schwach sind, die auf der Erde durch die Schwerkraft überdeckt würden, weil die Wiese nicht größer ist. Um Größenordnungen größer kann man besser untersuchen, wenn ich in eine Umgebung gehe, wo die Schwerkraft abgeschaltet ist. Dann gibt es materialwissenschaftliche Untersuchungen, also bestimmte Legierungen. Die Art und Weise, wie Legierungen entstehen, kann ich gut unter Schwerelosigkeit untersuchen. Diese Ergebnisse kann ich dann wieder rückspeisen in die Methoden, um Legierungen auf der Erde zu erzeugen. Das ist eine weitere Klasse von Experimenten, die da oben durchgeführt werden. Das war jetzt schon mal ein ganzes Spektrum von Experimenten, die die Schwerelosigkeit betreffen. Dann gibt es aber noch eine Ausnahme. Es gibt auch etwas weiteres Besonderes da oben. Das ist die Strahlung, die man da oben hat außerhalb der Atmosphäre. Dazu gibt es eben astronomische Experimente, die die Partikelstrahlung von der Sonne untersuchen oder es gibt Experimente mit Langzeitmissionen zum Mars. Wie ist der Einfluss der Strahlung auf die Astronauten? Ein russisches Experiment Matroshka zum Beispiel, was doch geführt wird, wo man untersucht, wie die Strahlung sich auf menschenähnliche Substanzen ausführt.
Das ist dieses Experiment, wo auch so eine menschenähnliche Puppe eingesetzt wird und dann mit entsprechenden Sensoren ausgestattet ist.
Das ist so jetzt die Bandbreite von Experimenten, die wir da oben haben.
Und wie viele sind da so jetzt auch wirklich aktiv?
Weiß ich nicht genau, da müsste man so 10, 20, 100, 200, sowas, so die Größenordnung. Eher in dem 10, 20er Bereich.
Okay, sodass quasi die betreuenden Astronauten über den Tag immer mit einigen irgendwie in Verbindung sind, mit manchen dann wiederum nicht, aber dann am nächsten Tag vielleicht andere betreuen. So muss man sich das vorstellen. Genau. Gib mir auch gleich noch mal Gelegenheit, hier noch mal ein paar Querverweise zu machen. Da habe ich schon schwer mit gerechnet, dass wir bei dem heutigen Thema eine ganze Menge Verweise auf andere Sendungen machen können. Forschung und Schwerelosigkeit war hier ein Thema in der 26. Ausgabe. Eine sehr lange Ausgabe, aber die sich wirklich lohnt. Auch die ISS und Raumstationen als solche kamen hier schon mal zum Gespräch. Da war ich auch schon mal hier vor Ort mit Reinhold Ewald, dem jeweiligen Astronauten, der auch auf der Mir war, wo wir über die Aspekte der Raumstationen als solche gesprochen haben. Jetzt vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen mehr auf den Aspekt des Bodensegments. Da oben sind die Astronauten, die Technik läuft, man muss es von hier unten überwachen. Wie läuft das jetzt konkret ab? Also es gibt hier diesen großen Raum, viele Bildschirme an den Tischen, viele Bildschirme an der Wand. Wie groß ist so ein Team, was sich jetzt darum kümmert?
Also das erkläre ich vielleicht am besten am Beispiel der Satelliten, weil die einen Aspekt noch ein bisschen mehr abdecken. Bei den Satelliten sind wir ja auch für die komplette Steuerung des Satelliten selbst verantwortlich. Das ist etwas, was bei der Betreuung des Columbus-Moduls wegfällt. Das hängt ja an der ISS dran. Und die ISS wird dann von Houston oder von Moskau ausgesteuert. Das heißt, ich erkläre das jetzt am besten am Beispiel Satelliten, weil das dann einen gesamtheitlichen Betrieb besser darstellt. Also wenn ich von oben so auf den Kontrollraum drauf gucke, haben wir ja vorhin gemacht, dann sehe ich einen Kontrollraum mit einer ganzen Reihe von Konsolen, die dort sind. Das kann man sich vorstellen wie die Brücke von so einem Hochseetanker. Da gibt es eine Position, das ist der sogenannte Command-Operator. Das ist die einzige Position, die Kommandos zum Satelliten raufschicken kann und darf. Der Command-Operator ist jetzt, wenn ich den Vergleich mit der Sehfahrt weiter bemühe, ist der Steuermann auf der Brücke des Schiffes bzw. derjenige, der die Kommandos dann zum Satelliten raufschickt.
Also nicht unbedingt der Kapitän, sondern derjenige, der wirklich Verbindung mit der Maschine hat.
Wobei, was nicht ganz äquivalent ist zum Steuermann auf dem Boot. Der Steuermann legt eine Rute und das Boot fährt eine Kurve. Beim Satelliten ist es nicht ganz so schnell. Die Kommandos, die wir raufschicken, sind in der Regel zeit-timetagged, also Zeit markiert, sodass es in einem Zeitraum von 12 oder 48 Stunden irgendeine Operation auslöst.
Also man schickt die Befehle schon mal vor und das Gerät weiß, wann es was zu tun hat, aber man macht das halt nicht sofort.
Genau. Erstens hängt dann von zwei Dingen ab. Erstens hat man auch Zeitverlauf, das in Ruhe alles zu planen, die Manöver, und vorab die Kommandos raufzuschicken. Und zweitens hat man mit dem Satelliten in der Regel ja nicht immer Kontakt, sondern gerade bei Erdbeobachtungssatelliten, nur an wenigen Zeiten während seines Umlaufs um die Erde Kontakt. Also das war jetzt die Position des Kommandopereiters, der schickt die Kommandos nach oben. Der Kommandopereiter macht das aber nicht nach gut dünken, sondern kriegt die Anweisung mehr oder weniger vom Flugdirektor, der sitzt im Kontrollraum in der Mitte hinten. Und der Flugdirektor ist so was wie der Kapitän in dem Kontrollraum, der die Fäden zusammenhält. Dann gibt es an den anderen Konsolen den sogenannten Subsystem-Operator. Jedes Subsystem-Operator ist für eine bestimmte Funktion im Satelliten verantwortlich, überwacht die und empfiehlt dann gegebenenfalls ein bestimmtes Kommando raufzuschicken und dort auszulösen. Macht das aber alles über den Flugdirektor. Kommuniziert wird dort im Kontrollraum über Voice Loops. Also die Operator haben dann ähnliche Kopfhörer und Mikrofone auf, wie wir gerade. Das gesprochene Wort ist Gesetz, sagt man. Das ist ähnlich wie bei den Fluglotsen am Flugfeld, die in verschiedenen Kanälen sprechen. Hat man im Kontrollraum auch bestimmte Voice Loops, die man anwählen kann und auf denen man entweder nur zuhören kann oder auch sprechen kann? Gute Frage. Das ist eine ganz eigene Sprache, die englisch ist oder dem Englischen entlehnt ist, aber einen ganz eigenen Wortschatz hat. Also wenn ich frage, hast du mich verstanden, dann sage ich nicht, did you understand me, sondern do you read me? Und deine Antwort wäre dann nicht yes, I did, I'm in a studio oder so was, sondern copy.
Oder auch, I'm sorry Dave, I can't do that.
Also ein bisschen auch wie in der Seemannschaft, da gibt es für jede Funktion einen wohl definierten Ausdruck, den man dann wählt und spricht.
Aber es ist sehr wichtig, dass man in dieser Sprache, es ist im Prinzip eine extrem formale Sprache, in der man eben auch explizit Bestätigung einfordert und wenn man diese nicht erhält, müsste man dann entsprechend wiederholen etc. Also man redet eigentlich ein bisschen mehr so wie Computer miteinander reden.
Könnte man sagen, ja. Also das ist etwas, was man wirklich trainieren muss, auch für die Operator. Die Sprache, mit der man spricht, da unten, deswegen braucht auch so eine Mission relativ lange Vorbereitung und die Operator lernen das bei Training on the Job hier bei uns. Wir haben auch eigene Kurse, sag ich mal, einmal im Jahr machen wir so einen Spacecraft Operations Kurs, da haben wir On-Console Trainings mit drin eingebaut, sodass Leute, die von außerhalb kommen und das später mal irgendwo machen wollen, oder die Partner von uns, die im Raumsegment Satelliten bauen und die mal verstehen wollen, wie wir den Betrieb machen, die haben dann auch mal die Gelegenheit da an einem Kurs teilzunehmen und das zu trainieren und zu lernen.
Findet dann im Kontrollraum eigentlich noch irgendein normaler Sprachdialog statt oder redet man da wirklich die ganze Schicht über wirklich nur in dieser Protokollsprache?
Nein, da findet schon auch normale Sprache statt. Gerade bei den Erdbeobachtungssatelliten, die sehr niedrig fliegen, hat man ja nur zu wenigen Zeiten Kontakt mit dem Satelliten. Das heißt, wenn wir nur unsere Bodenstation in Weilheim verwenden zum Beispiel, fliegt ein Satellit viermal am Tag über diese Bodenstation und hat eine durchschnittliche Kontaktzeit von sieben bis zehn Minuten. Und dann ist er wieder weg. Und in dieser Zeit ist natürlich hoch spannend und konzentriert dann die Arbeit zur Kontaktaufnahme. Dann kriegen wir die Telemetriedaten in der Anfangsphase und dann schicken wir in der zweiten Phase die Telekommandos nach oben. Da ist natürlich höchste Konzentration und eine sehr formale Sprache.
Das heißt, genau über diese zehn Minuten, 15 Minuten vielleicht, mit Vorbereitung und Nachbereitung, da ist man dann einfach im Grunde.
Oder die Vorbereitungsteilung zu einem Kontakt ist dann auch sehr formal, wenn man da drin ist. Dann ist aber irgendwie eine Sequenz wieder zu Ende. Und dann kann man auch einen Kopfhörer wieder runternehmen und verlängst dann auch den Kontakt.
Ich denke, das ist auch extrem wichtig einfach, dass man Fehler vermeidet und Missverständnisse vermeidet vor allem.
Also da arbeitet man zum Beispiel auch mit dem Licht in einem Erdbeobachtungskontrollraum. Wird das Licht gedimmt und wird auf Dunkeln gemacht, wenn man sich für einen Überflug und für einen Kontakt vorbereitet. Während des Kontakts ist auch das Licht unten.
Ist das jetzt, dass man die Bildschirme besser lesen kann? Oder geht es da jetzt nur darum, dass so ein Signal ist?
Das ist ein Signal für die Operator im Raum. Jetzt wird es ernst. Jetzt setzt man an den Konsolen und jetzt geht das formale Programm los. Dann verschwindet irgendwann der Satellit aus dem Empfangsbereich der Antenne. Dann schließt man das Ganze noch ab. Dann lässt der Flugdirektor das Licht wieder anmachen. Dann ist erstmal Entspannung angesagt. Dann kann man zu einer Nachbesprechung in einem separaten Raum gehen, wo man auch ein bestimmtes Manöver nachbespricht.
Aber der Satellit ist eigentlich 24 Stunden in Beobachtung. Das heißt, es ist auch immer jemand da?
Es ist immer jemand da, aber nur dann, wenn wir Kontakt haben. Das ist unterschiedlich von Mission zu Mission, und das macht auch die Unterschiede in der Missionsbetreuung aus. Bei Columbus haben wir fast immer Kontakt zu den Astronauten und zum Columbus-Modulen. Das hängt daher, dass die Amerikaner ein Kommunikationssystem über Tidris, also das sind Relais-Satelliten, eingerichtet haben. Das heißt, man kommuniziert von uns vom Kontrollraum aus nach USA, von USA aus über die geostationären Kommunikationssatelliten und dann runter zur Internationalen Raumstation im niedrigen Erdorbit. Dadurch habe ich fast eine komplette Abdeckung, aber nicht ganz. Also es gibt Kommunikationslücken, immer mal wieder. Und in den Zeiten hat man keinen Kontakt zu den Astronauten, man kriegt keine Videobilder von oben. Das weiß man auch vorher alles. Und die Astronauten genießen das auch manchmal, nicht permanent überwacht zu sein.
Wie lange sind diese Pausen?
Das sind immer wieder so Stücke von ein paar Minuten, zehn Minuten.
Und wir reden jetzt über Sprachkommunikation. Das ist sowohl Sprache als auch Video.
Also bei der ISS ist es S-Band für Sprachkommunikation und KU-Band für Videokommunikation. Bei den Erdbeobachtungssatelliten hat man eben TMTC-Kommunikation nennt man das, also Telemetrie und Telekommandkommunikation.
Also das Empfang von Messdaten und Heraufsenden von Kommandos.
Das Empfang der Telemetriedaten, das heißt nicht die Messdaten in dem Sinne, sondern die Zustandsdaten des Satelliten. Die gehen über S-Band mit einer niedrigen Bandbreite. Die Nutzlastdaten, das können jetzt Messdaten sein, oder in der Regel sind es Bilder, sind große Datenmengen, die kommen dann über ein anderes Band runter, derzeit über X-Band, aber zunehmend über kurzwelligere Bänder wie KA-Band, weil man dort mehr höhere Datendichte herunterbringt.
Und das Video-Bild, das man da so kriegt, das kann man da drauf erkennen, oder ist das alles nur so verschwommen?
Das Video-Bild von der ISS, da kann man einiges ganz gut erkennen. Das geht über KU-Band runter und hat so eine, weiß nicht welche Auflösung.
Eine ordentliche Video-Auflösung. Ist jetzt nicht mehr so wie Mondlandung damals, so verschwommene Bilder, schwarz-weiß? Und man kann sich dann quasi über jede Kamera anschalten, die man jetzt gerade sehen will, oder die werden sowieso alle parallel übertragen?
Im Columbus-Modul, wenn ein Columbus-Betrieb ist, kann man natürlich die Columbus-Kameras anschalten. Ansonsten kriegen wir auch die Kameras der NASA-Bilder zu uns direkt geleitet. Man kann sich übrigens über NASA TV im Internet permanent Live-Daten von der ISS anschauen. Also ein bisschen Zeitverzöger.
Also nicht nur Daten, sondern auch Bilder?
Live-Bilder, ja. Also kann jeder schauen, Google NASA TV. Da sieht man permanent einen Datenstrom, der dann unterbrochen ist mit Sondersendungen. Aber das NASA TV ist sicher für Zuhörer auch mal eine Möglichkeit, sich da Bilder von der ISS anzuschauen.
Vielleicht noch mal zu dem Bodenteam. Also hat man ja schon festgestellt, Columbus hat andere Anforderungen. Aber dafür ist da eben auch sehr viel mehr Präsenz angesagt. Klar, weil man muss ja jederzeit in der Lage sein, auch mit den Leuten dort zu sprechen, wenn irgendein Problem auftritt. Und Probleme können ja im Prinzip jederzeit auftreten. Grundsätzlich ist es aber bei allen Bereichen so, man hat einfach so einen permanenten Schichtbetrieb. Das heißt, es ist eigentlich immer ein Team da, mehr oder weniger stark besetzt vielleicht, je nachdem welche Anforderungen da sind. Aber es ist nicht so, dass hier irgendwann mal einer rausgeht, das Licht ausschaltet und dann ist nichts. Sondern hier ist einfach immer irgendwas los. Das heißt ja auch, dass man dann erheblichen Personalaufwand für jede einzelne Mission treiben muss. Einerseits braucht man ja genug Leute. Man muss auch für Krankheitsfälle etc. und Urlaub gerüstet sein. Das ist schon ein relativ hoher Personalaufwand, oder? Übertreibe ich jetzt?
Das kann man sagen, dass der Personalaufwand doch relativ hoch ist. Man muss ja vorstellen, für einen Mitarbeiter, der dort unten permanent sitzt, eine Position, die sie mal 24 Stunden an 365 Tagen besetzt ist, brauche ich fünf bis sechs Mitarbeiter, um diese Position zu besetzen. Ich brauche also an einem Tag 24 Stunden. Da habe ich eine Schicht, die 8,5 Stunden dauert. Oder ich habe drei Schichten, 8,5 Stunden. Das heißt, man hat eine halbe Stunde Überlaub für die Übergabe. Das ist das, was wir vorhin gesehen haben im Kontrollraum. Da waren an einer Position zwei Leute. Das heißt, dafür drei. Aber diese Mitarbeiter haben natürlich auch Wochenende und Feiertage frei und haben Urlaub. Und um dann wirklich das komplette Jahr abdecken zu können, brauche ich so fünf bis sechs Mitarbeiter für pro Position.
Und die müssen ja auch Bescheid wissen, ausgebildet sein, eine Mission kennen etc.
Brauchen das Training, die Zertifizierung, bevor sie überhaupt zugelassen sind, da unten ihren Job zu tun und so weiter und so fort. Das ist durchaus ein Personalaufwand, ein hoher. Deswegen haben wir als einer der ersten Kontrollzentren in Europa ja auch die Idee des Multimissionsbetriebs eingeführt, den wir zunächst bei den Erdbeobachtungsmissionen etabliert haben. Und die Idee ist ganz einfach. Ich habe halbes Dutzend von Missionen, die alle nur kurze Kontakte haben. Also typisches Beispiel ist eine Erdbeobachtungsmission im 500-km-Orbit. Da wollen wir natürlich unsere eigene Bodenstation in Weilheim benutzen. Die fliegen einmal über Weilheim drüber. Nach sieben Minuten ist der Kontakt zu Ende oder zehn Minuten. Dann fliegen sie beim nächsten Umlauf nochmal über Weilheim drüber. Das heißt, ich habe zwei Kontakte kurz hintereinander, also nach anderthalb Stunden. In der Zwischenzeit dreht sich die Erde unter dem Orbit. Also in 90 Minuten ist ein Orbit, die Erde dreht sich ein Stück. Das heißt, ich habe zwei Kontakte kurz hintereinander. Und dann erst wieder nach zwölf Stunden. Und da habe ich auch wieder zwei Kontakte. Das ist natürlich Gift für eine Schicht. Ich kann also diesen einen Satelliten nicht mit einer Schicht betreiben, obwohl die Kontakte nur hochgerechnet vier Mal zehn Minuten, also 40 Minuten sind. Diese 40 Minuten kann ich aber nicht mit einem Team abdecken, weil sonst müsste ich das Team vormittags reinkommen lassen. Um zehn Uhr sind die Kontakte zum Beispiel. Dann schicke ich die aber wieder nach Hause. Und dann dürfen sie nach acht Stunden wieder kommen und müssen zehn Uhr abends auch noch das abdecken.
Das geht natürlich nicht.
Deswegen haben wir gesagt, warum nehmen wir nicht ein Dutzend Missionen oder ein bisschen weniger, ein bisschen mehr, werfen die in einem gemeinsamen Betrieb. Und ein Multimissionsoperator muss dann in der Lage sein, also ein Dutzend ist ein bisschen viel, aber ein halbes Dutzend, also sechs Missionen, muss dann in der Lage sein, ein Kommandooperator. Diese Missionen nicht gleichzeitig, aber zeitlich versetzt zu betreiben. Es geht aber nur, wenn die Missionen ähnliche Mission-Kontrollsysteme haben und ähnliche Arten, die zu bedienen. Weil man von einem Operator auch nicht erwarten kann, dass er sechs verschiedene, grundlegend verschiedene Mission-Kontrollsysteme erlernen und gleichzeitig in kurzer Zeit auch ausüben kann. Dazu muss man eben dann auch die Satellitenhersteller dazu bringen, dann mit uns zu kooperieren, dass man die Bediensoftware, sage ich mal, so anpasst, dass sie dem Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum passt und nicht dem Satelliten passt.
Das heißt, man einigt sich dann auch frühzeitig schon in der Planung auf entsprechende Standards und Protokolle etc.? Seit wann gibt es das so in der Form?
Anfang dieses Jahrtausends, also 2000 nochmals, haben wir angefangen, diesen Multimissionsbetrieb einzurichten und zu etablieren. Und das ist natürlich eine erhebliche Kostenersparnis.
Obwohl man auf ein gewisser Hinsicht natürlich erst mal einen höheren Schulungsaufwand hat für den einzelnen Mitarbeiter, der ja dann sozusagen noch mehr Missionen kennen muss, auch wenn sie sich vielleicht ähnlich bedienen. Aber wir haben ja dann alle auch irgendwie andere Anforderungen, nehme ich an.
Richtig, die Operator müssen mehr Missionen kennen. Auf der einen Seite muss man auch frühzeitig in die Mission mit eingebunden sein und mit dem Raumsegment, mit dem Hersteller des Satelliten sich auf ein Verfahren einigen können, was eben auch gut zum Kontrollzentrum passt. Entweder eine universelle Schnittstelle hat und ein universelles Verfahren hat oder einfach auch in die Kontrollraumumgebung passt.
Was sind das für, bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei den Mitarbeitern selber, was müssen die für so eine Ausbildung machen, um im Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum solche Missionssteuerungen vorzunehmen?
Also Hochschulabschluss in der Regel im wissenschaftlich-technischen Bereich. Die größte Fraktion davon ist Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik, also Ingenieure in der Luft- und Raumfahrttechnik. Aber es gibt am ganzen naturwissenschaftlichen Bereich alle möglichen Studienabgänger. Also ich bin Physiker und Astrophysiker, um konkret zu sein. Wir haben Chemiker hier, unser früherer Institutsleiter war Chemiker. Wir haben Geologen bei uns. Und natürlich im Bereich mit den Bodenstationen und Netzwerken haben wir natürlich Techniker, Informatiker, Mathematiker, ganze Bandbreite.
Das ist wiederkehrendes Thema hier, dass man eigentlich über so ziemlich alle akademischen Wege in irgendeiner Form hier seinen Platz finden kann. Auch denselben Platz über verschiedene Einstiege. Wichtiger ist vor allem, dass man sich überhaupt mit Wissenschaft und vielleicht auch ein bisschen mit Luft- und Raumfahrt beschäftigt hat, um hier die richtigen Voraussetzungen zu haben. Aber dann ist es eigentlich nur auch eine Frage der internen Weiterbildung.
Also wissenschaftlich-technisch sollte es sein. Es muss nicht unbedingt Raumfahrt sein. Also ein E-Techniker, der rüberkommt und vor allem Rechensendungsbetrieb gemacht hat mit irgendwas SAP-Lösungen, kann auch doch aus seinem Platz hier finden. Er muss nicht vorher Raumfahrt gemacht haben. Aber wissenschaftlich-technisch sollte es schon sein. Hat auch ein bisschen was mit dem Gehaltsstruktur zu tun. Wir sind ja eine wissenschaftliche Einrichtung, die dem Tarifvertrag öffentlicher Dienst angelegt ist und haben quasi wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiter in dem Sinne. Ganz self-made Quereinsteige haben es schwierig, in dieses Gehaltsschema, Gehaltsstruktur eine vernünftige Position zu finden. Das ist immer mal wieder ein Punkt, der es schwierig macht, irgendjemand, der zwar gut ist, aber jetzt keinen offiziellen Diplom oder so etwas in der Tasche hat, einzustellen bei uns.
Wir waren ja vorhin bei dem Aufbau des Teams so ein bisschen abgerutscht dann auch in Richtung Columbus-Spezifika. Also wir hatten diesen Command-Operator, Flight Director, Subsystem-Operator. Ist das im Wesentlichen die Teamstruktur schon gewesen? Oder gibt es da noch andere Aufgaben? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass gerade im Zusammenspiel mit den Astronauten da noch andere Tätigkeitsbereiche hier definiert werden. Also wird dann hier die Betreuung der Astronauten selbst auch von hier gemacht?
Also um zu Columbus zu kommen, da gibt es auch den Flight Director natürlich. Da gibt es System, das ist ein Subsystem. Das heißt System, die kümmern sich ums Gesamtsystem. Da gibt es CallOC, also Operations-Coordinator, die sich quasi um die Experimente kümmern. Da gibt es Data Management. Was du gerade im Kopf hattest, ist die sogenannte Eurocom-Position, die dem CAPCOM entspricht. Das ist ein spezielles Subsystem-Operator, der trainiert hat, mit den Astronauten direkt Kontakt aufzunehmen. In der Regel sind das entweder Astronauten, die früher mal auf der Raumstation waren, oder es sind Ausbilder aus dem Astronautentrainingszentrum, die die Astronauten ganz gut kennen und von daher auch gut und effizient mit den Astronauten sprechen können. Die Position ist immer dann besetzt, wenn ein Astronaut im Columbus-Modul ist, weil es gar nicht so häufig ist. Die ESA hat, wie sie sich auf der ISS eingebracht hat, auch 8% Astronautenzeit zugebilligt bekommen. Das heißt, 8% der verfügbaren Zeit der Astronauten, die da oben sind, können für das Columbus-Modul eingesetzt werden. Das ist gar nicht so viel. Man sieht, dass die meiste Zeit des Columbus-Modul unbemannt ist. Das heißt, die Experimente dort müssen vom Boden aus remote gesteuert werden. Sie müssen auch so designt sein, dass sie meistens eben remote gesteuert werden können. Nur in manchen Fällen, wo ein Reck gewechselt werden muss, brauchen wir natürlich Astronauten. Das muss aber dann sehr sorgfältig im Vornherein geplant und beantragt werden. Es ist oft gar nicht so leicht zu kriegen, wenn man das nicht von vornherein eingeplant hat, dass da Astronauten-Zeit notwendig ist.
Das heißt, man braucht eigentlich eine irre Vorlaufzeit, um diese Planung wirklich effizient hinzubekommen. Man weiß, man hat so und so viel Prozent Astronautenzeit. Das heißt auch, dass nicht unbedingt immer derselbe Astronaut dort ist. Ich glaube, es sind nicht alle ausgebildet für Columbus, aber es ist mehr als einer.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele für Columbus ausgebildet sind.
Auf jeden Fall nicht alle.
Vorzugsweise natürlich die europäischen Astronauten, die dann oben sind.
Das heißt, wenn etwas Größeres umgebaut werden muss, oder jetzt, zum Zeitpunkt dieser Aufnahme dieses Gesprächs von ein paar Tagen, ist ja das ATV 3, auch schon mal ein Thema hier bei Raumzeit, ist ja gerade wieder angedockt. Das ist natürlich ein Ereignis besonderer Aktivität, weil da muss natürlich das neue Material entsprechend herausgeholt werden, da muss viel installiert werden, es muss das alte, nicht mehr verwendete Material und die sonstigen Abfälle dann wieder zurück transportiert werden, über einen längeren Zeitraum. Ich glaube, das ATV bleibt jetzt ein paar Monate sogar, fast ein halbes Jahr an der ISS angedockt. Also das sind ja dann so besondere Ereignisse, die natürlich auch lange Zeit im Voraus geplant wurden, wo dann die Astronauten auch voll eingebunden wird. Aber das hat dann eben auch wiederum konkrete Auswirkungen aufs Columbus-Modul und damit natürlich auch hier auf den Betrieb.
Ja, ATV dockt ja an der anderen Seite an. Das ATV bringt ja auch Experimente für das Columbus-Modul. Also in dem Sinne hat es auch Auswirkungen. Und beim ATV wird das nicht direkt von Oberpfaffenhofen ausgestattet, sondern von Toulouse. Wir funktionieren aber hier als Kommunikationsdrehscheibe auch für den ATV.
Ich wollte eigentlich auch mehr auf diese eigentliche Planung hinaus. Also man weiß, dass das ATV kommt. Man weiß also im Monat, vielleicht Jahre auch im Voraus, da wird dann dieses Experiment da sein. Da muss man im Prinzip so eine detaillierte Planung machen, um dann eben auch genau sagen zu können, ja, hier in zwei Wochen um 14 Uhr, da brauchen wir dann irgendwie uns zustehende Astronautenzeit, um einfach diese Umbaumaßnahme, so altes Experiment, was abgeschlossen ist, wird abgebaut, neues Experiment wird eingesetzt etc. Wer macht das?
Das wird hiermit erstellt, also die Timeline, die Missionsplanung wird hiermit erstellt, und zwar langfristig, mittelfristig und kurzfristig erstellt und muss aber auch ausgehandelt werden, natürlich mit den Wissenschaftlern oder den Anforderungen von der Raumstation, die von außen kommen. Wenn zum Beispiel ATV Doct anbringt etwas, was ins Columbus-Modul kommt, dann wird das natürlich über die NASA mit eingeplant, weil das ist dann ein übergeordnetes Thema, dass da was angeliefert wird oder irgendwie von der Raumstation aus bestimmte Anforderungen da sind, dass entweder nichts gemacht werden darf oder kein Strom zur Verfügung steht oder limitierter Strom zur Verfügung steht, das kommt über die NASA. Und ansonsten treiben natürlich die Experimente auch die Missionsplanung im Columbus-Modul. Das muss dann auf Experimentsseite ausgehandelt werden, wer wann wie viel Ressourcen bekommt. Und wird wirklich langfristig geplant.
Diese Eurocom-Position, derjenige, der jetzt konkret mit dem Astronauten spricht, das ist so eine Position, wo dann auch häufig ehemalige Astronauten eingesetzt werden. Und das vor allem, weil die natürlich nicht nur viel darüber wissen, sondern die sozusagen auch wissen, wie es sich anfühlt, Astronaut zu sein. Das ist also im Wesentlichen eine psychologische Schulung, die an der Stelle erforderlich ist. Macht das diese Position so besonders?
Na ja, wie in jedem Team ist es besser, wenn man sich kennt und angefasst hat und in die Augen geschaut hat. Und dann funktioniert auch das Telefonieren leichter. Das heißt, ich kann eine Telefonkonferenz mit Projektpartnern viel besser machen, wenn ich die am Anfang vom Projekt mal wirklich gesehen habe und abends mit dem Essen war. Als wenn das einer ist, den ich nur per Video sehe. Und genauso ist es auch mit der Kommunikation vom Eurocom zu den Astronauten. Ich denke mal, das ist der Punkt.
Damit erklärt sich auch, warum Astronautenausbildung hier auch Teil dieses Instituts ist.
Weil das einfach ein Teil des Ablaufs sein muss. Das ist einer der Gründe, warum das DLR auch das Astronautentrainingszentrum unterstützt, das ja eigentlich eine ESA-Einrichtung ist. Die Leitung des Astronautentrainings ist Sache des ESAs. Aber das DLR hat da quasi einen Pool von Mitarbeitern in dem Astronautentraining dran.
Ich kann heute hier fast alle Sendungen, die wir schon bei Raumzeit hatten, verweisen.
Habe ich so langsam den Eindruck.
Ausgabe 11 dreht sich genau um das ESA-Astronauten-Ausbildungszentrum in Köln, wo ich mit der angehenden Astronautin bzw. jetzt schon ihre Ausbildung abgeschlossen habe, der Astronautin Samantha Christopheretti, gesprochen habe, die noch keine Mission zugeteilt bekommen hat, aber die eben sehr ausführlich Auskunft gegeben hat, wie es so ist, so ausgebildet zu werden als Astronaut. Auch ein extrem unterhaltsames und informatives Gespräch gewesen. Das heißt, hier ist so, das GSOC ist vor allem so eine viel gelebte Routine, wo viel Planung erforderlich ist. Jetzt kommen wir doch vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen zu dem Bereich, der vor allem dich hier treibt. Diese Geschäftsfelder, die sich abzeichnen. Also derzeit gibt es Erdbeobachtungen, es gibt diese permanente Mission Columbus, der ISS. Was sind denn so die anderen Dinge, die wir vielleicht jetzt noch nicht angesprochen haben, die hier auch noch betrieben werden, oder die sich so in Zukunft abzeichnen?
Also noch mal zusammenfassen, was unsere Hauptgeschäftshelder sind, die wir schon seit langen Jahren machen, war also Columbusbetrieb, ISS, Erdbeobachtung, zweites, Navigation, Galileo-Satelliten, da bereiten wir uns schon seit langem vor und das ist jetzt ein eigener Gebäude. Und die Kommunikationssatelliten, da haben wir wirklich eine ganze Flotte von Satelliten positioniert für einen kommerziellen Betreiber, für Eutelsat haben wir wirklich viele Satelliten positioniert und auch die Fernsehsatelliten, die wir in Deutschland hier empfangen, ist eine gute Chance dabei, dass der auf einen Satelliten ausgerichtet ist, den wir damals positioniert haben. Das sind so die gängigen Geschäftsfelder, die wir schon auch traditionell machen. Ein Thema, das neu gerade aufkommt, ist Raumfahrt-Robotik. Das ist jetzt auch ein besonderes Thema in Konferenzen. Oder auch im deutschen Fokus der Raumfahrt findet man das immer wieder, dass wir in der Raumfahrt-Robotik Missionen fliegen wollen und die gerade vorbereiten. Wir sind gerade dabei, eine Mission namens DEOS vorzubereiten, das heißt Deutsche Orbitaliservicing-Mission. Da sind wir mitten in der Phase B, also noch bei der Papierarbeit. Diese Mission hat zum Ziel, einen zweiten Satelliten oder nachzuweisen und zu demonstrieren, dass wir in der Lage sind, einen Satelliten, der nicht kooperativ ist und nicht aktiv gesteuert wird und sogar ein bisschen taumelt und sich da oben dreht, dass wir in der Lage sind, mit einem Service-Satelliten diesen taumelten Satelliten einzufangen und gezielt dann zu entsorgen, das heißt zu deorbiten und in der Atmosphäre verklühen zu lassen. Das ist eine Art von Mission, auf die wir uns vorbereiten durch Studien und Konzepte. Eine andere Art von Mission ist, man möchte einen Satelliten bauen, der zu den teuren geostationären Kommunikationssatelliten fliegen kann, dort an diese Satelliten undockt. Und zwar in einem Moment, in dem der Treibstoff den Satelliten zu Ende geht oder nahezu zu Ende ist. Und sie dann eigentlich auf den Weltraumfriedhof gebracht werden müssen. Aber wenn ich einen an den Satelliten andocken kann, mit einem Service-Satelliten, der die Bahn-Lager-Regelung übernehmen kann, kann ich die Lebenszeit von diesen teuren Kommunikationssatelliten verlängern. Das ist ein Projekt, das wir untersucht haben namens OLEF, Orbital Life Extension Vehicle. Es ist momentan nicht ganz aktiv, weil die Finanzierung da nicht zustande gekommen ist. Aber das sind Technologien, die wir erprobt haben und entwickelt haben, wie zum Beispiel das Docking-Tool, was in der Lage ist, quasi an die Apogeumstüse eines geostationären Satelliten zu docken und den festzuhalten.
Dazu hatte ich hier auch schon wieder ein Gespräch. Raumzeit Nummer 14, Robotik in der Raumfahrt, mit Klaus Lanzel, der in diesem Bereich vor allem eine der treibenden Kräfte und Wissenschaftler ist. Wer sich jetzt für diese Details interessiert, dass alles auch nochmal ausführlich dargestellt wird, welche Ideen da sind. Die Gründe dafür sind ja auch klar. Auf der einen Seite würde das die Wirtschaftlichkeit erhöhen. Das ist sehr viel einfacher, wenn man einfach nur noch so einen angehängten Treibstofftank hinterher schickt, der dann eben einen ansonsten brachliegenden Satelliten einfach noch weiter betreiben lässt, weil der Rest der Technik ist ja noch da, nicht nur, dass der Treibstoff halt fehlt, weil er eben endlich ist. Und die Problematik des taumelnden Satellitens ist natürlich vor allem eine Frage des Weltraumschrotz und dessen Vermeidung bzw. vielleicht eben auch Entsorgung. Das ist ja eigentlich so das noch ungelöste Thema in diesem Bereich. Also wenn man das da oben hat, dann kann man natürlich ausweichen. Man kann es beobachten. Hier in Ausgabe 34 haben wir auch über Space Situational Awareness, das große Programm der ESA, gesprochen, wo jetzt alle möglichen Maßnahmen konsolidiert werden, um überhaupt erst mal zu wissen, was geht da draußen, wo sind die Gefahren. Das spielt natürlich eine Rolle, aber man ist natürlich noch besser dran, wenn man eben diese ganzen Elemente auch wirklich entfernen könnte. Auch das ist natürlich ein großer Aufwand. Und das ist jetzt sozusagen in dieses DEOS-Projekt eingebunden.
Da ist das DEOS-Projekt ein erster Schritt dazu, mal das nachzufassen. Also es gibt zwei Themen. Erstens möchte man natürlich ein Objekt, das man raufgebracht hat, sich in der Lage sein, es sicher wieder runterzubringen, weil es könnte als Ganzes irgendwo runterfliegen und da Schaden anzurichten. Das ist eine Problematik, die allerdings nicht die größte ist. Die größere Problematik ist, dass wir inzwischen unsere Bahnen durch den zunehmenden Weltraum Müll irgendwann unbenutzbar machen. Es gibt da jetzt diverse Studien, die vorhersagen, wie sich die Dichte des Weltraummülls entwickelt. Es gibt eine bestimmte Bahnhöhe zwischen 800 und 1.000 Kilometer bei hohen Inklinationen, das heißt polnahe Bahnen. Da sagt man voraus, dass diese Bahnen, auch wenn kein einziger weiteres Satellit mehr gestartet wird, die Dichte des Weltraummülls über die nächsten hunderte von Jahren permanent zunimmt, und zwar in einer Art und Weise, dass diese Bahnhöhe dann nicht mehr benutzt werden kann.
Also es nimmt zu, weil immer weitere Objekte hinein absacken?
Nicht durchs Absacken, nein, das ist doch ein Kaskadeneffekt. Man hat also da jetzt große Erdbeobachtungs-Satelliten, wie zum Beispiel Envisat, das ist ein großer ESA-Satellit von 8 Tonnen etwa. Und diese Satelliten können, und das hat sich 2009 durch diese Satelliten-Kollision gezeigt, können entweder durch einen anderen Satelliten getroffen werden, der nicht mehr steuerbar ist, oder sie können durch ein Drum-Weltraum-Müll in Faustgröße getroffen werden und zersplittern dann in Tausende von Bruchteilen. Diese Bruchteile wiederum erhöhen den Weltraummüll in dieser Bahnhöhe, treffen dann wiederum auf andere noch intakte Satelliten und zerschießen die auch wiederum in Tausende von Bruchteilen, sodass es einen Kaskadeneffekt dadurch entsteht.
Das heißt, es verstärkt sich einfach selbst und wird dann immer voller und immer schlimmer und unbenutzbarer?
Das kommt eben auch durch die große Geschwindigkeit in dieser Bahnhöhe. Man hat etwa 27.000 kmh Geschwindigkeit auf dieser Bahn. Und wenn man eine gegenläufige Bahn hat, oder in 90 Grad, trifft man eben mit so einer Geschwindigkeit bis zu 40.000 kmh Treffen die Objekte aufeinander. Und da langt schon ein Zentimeter großes Teil, um eine Sprengwirkung von einer Handgranate auszulösen.
Das heißt, diese Robotik-Forschung hat eine zunehmende Bedeutung, eine zunehmende Aufmerksamkeit.
Und zwar gibt es inzwischen etliche Analysen, die sagen, man muss pro Jahr aus dieser Region etwa fünf Objekte herunterholen, um diesen weiteren Anstieg zu dämmen. Das ist jetzt nicht etwas, was über mal sofort losgehen muss, aber man muss sich da Gedanken machen.
Objekte wie zum Beispiel diesen Envisat.
Wie zum Beispiel diesen Envisat muss man runterholen, um diese Bahnhöhen nutzbar zu lassen. Und dazu brauche ich Technologien wie DEOS. Man muss also in der Lage sein, an den hinzufliegen, ihn einzufangen. Und entweder hole ich ihn dann selbst runter mit dem Satelliten, den ich raufschicke. Also Harakiri-Methode nenne ich das immer. Oder ich bringe etwas an an dem Satelliten, was den großen Müllsatelliten, den übrig gebliebenen Alt-Satelliten, dann langsam runterbringt, sodass er irgendwann verglüht. Da gibt es alle möglichen Forschungsgebiete, Technologien, die man sich noch überlegen muss. Da gibt es schon eine ganze Reihe von Studien, die angefangen haben, aber so ein richtiges System hat man da noch nicht.
Aber ist es klar, dass die Wirtschaftlichkeit allein dadurch schon steigt? Weil wenn man es nicht tun würde, die Mission, die künftigen halt teurer oder eben auch schon unmöglich werden würden.
Also bestimmte Bahnhöhen wird man dann nicht mehr benutzen können, also so 800 bis 1000 Kilometer. Das ist eine gängige Bahnhöhe, die gern genommen wird, weil man weit genug weg ist von der Erde, dass man bei Erdbeochtung immer noch einen großen Streifen sieht. Aber nahe genug dran, um eine gute Auflösung zu haben.
Das heißt, das ist auch eine extrem wichtige?
Das ist eine wichtige Bahnhöhe, die man gerne nimmt. Das ist jetzt kein Problem, was in fünf Jahren die Benutzung dieses Orbits unmöglich macht. Aber so 50 Jahre oder 100 Jahre. Das ist vielleicht die Krux, weil man weit genug entfernt ist, um jetzt heute schon eine richtige Finanzierung auf die Beine zu stellen. Die Leute fragen mich immer, was habe ich jetzt davon, wenn ich einen Satelliten runterhole? Da muss ich auch um Größenordnung über 100 Millionen Euro in die Hand nehmen, um einen Satelliten runterzuholen. Das ist eine anspruchsvolle Mission und von daher interessant, weil ich Rondevue und Docking und Raumfahrt-Robotik machen kann und einen Satelliten einfangen. Das sind wichtige Technologien, die wir in Deutschland auch entwickelt haben über 20 Jahre. Das ist das Gespräch jetzt mit Klaus Landzettel auch. Das sollten wir mal auch zeigen, dass wir es tatsächlich in der Lage sind, weil bisher haben wir es noch nicht gezeigt. Wir haben das Rockwis-Experiment auf der Internationalen Raumstation, wo wir Roboterarme bewegen. Wir haben einzelne Komponenten gezeigt, aber eine komplette Mission, eine raumfahrt-robotische Mission, haben wir in dem Sinne noch nicht geflogen im On-Orbit-Servicing-Bereich.
Das heißt, im Prinzip findet hier auch jetzt noch mehr statt als nur Reaktion auf Anfragen von außen. Es geht eigentlich weit darüber hinaus, dass jetzt jemand klopft und sagt, wir haben hier einen Satelliten, wollte man nicht hier Backup sein oder vielleicht das Ding komplett betreiben. Sondern es geht eigentlich auch schon hin, steckt ja auch so ein bisschen in diesem Wort Entwicklung mit drin, selber mögliche Missionen zu beschreiben. Oder was umfasst dann konkret eure Tätigkeiten in dem Bereich? Also wie weit müsst ihr das selber jetzt entwickeln? Ist das eine technische Entwicklung oder ist das mehr so ein Demonstrieren der Notwendigkeiten und Zusammenhänge? Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Also im Bereich On-Office Servicing und Space Depri Mitigation oder Raumfahrt Robotischen Missionen sind wir in vielen Funktionen unterwegs. Wir sind einerseits ein Treiber, der auch ein gewisses Interesse hat, dass wir die Missionen langfristig fliegen können. Also nur als Beispiel, wir haben ein Team von ungefähr vier Mitarbeitern, die sich permanent mit Collision Avoidance und Beobachtung des Space Depris beschäftigen. Also das ist für so eine Größe von einem Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum. Also wir haben so 290 Mitarbeiter, sind schon immerhin vier Mitarbeiter, die sich permanent mit dem Thema Space Depri beschäftigen. Mit Collision Avoidance monitorieren unsere Satelliten und schauen, ob Kollisionsgefahr besteht. Falls eine Kollisionsgefahr besteht, rechnen wir aus, was wir ausmachen, wenn wir überfliegen müssen. Und dann wird noch mal entschieden, ob wir einen Auswahlmanöver fliegen oder nicht. Das heißt also, ein Prozent unserer Mitarbeiter ist für solche Tätigkeiten schon zuständig. Das wird zunehmend. Und zwar nicht nur bei uns, sondern europaweit oder weltweit werden die Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentren zunehmend einen Anteil von ihren Mitarbeitern mit den Auswirkungen des Weltrahm-Mülls beschäftigen müssen, dass die Auswahlmanöver fliegen, dass die diskalkulieren usw. Dann ist es nicht nur der Personalaufwand auf unserer Seite, sondern auch die Satelliten oben müssen, bei den Auswahlmanövern verbrauchen sie ja Treibstoff. Das heißt, sie müssen einen bestimmten Bruchteil ihres Treibstoffes für Auswahlmanöver reservieren. Und Treibstoff ist Masse und Masse ist Geld. Das heißt, ob ich jetzt bei einem Kommunikationssatelliten noch einen zusätzlichen Transponder mit rauftue oder den Treibstoff mitnehme, um ausweichen zu können, ist Geld wert. Transponder kann ich verkaufen, den Treibstoff nicht. Den brauche ich, um ausweichen zu können.
Genau, und vor allem verkürzt er die Mission.
Verkürzt die Lebenszeit bei einer Erdberuchtungsmission wie TerraSat ganz genau. Das sind also Auswirkungen, wo wir sagen, wir bräuchten sowas, wir würden gerne weniger Müll da oben haben. Das heißt, wir sind interessent, weniger Müll da oben zu haben. Auf der anderen Seite ist die Raumfahrt-Robotik natürlich aus unserer Sicht auch was Spannendes, weil es ist wesentlich spannender, an einen Satelitenrand zu fliegen, an den Anflug, Navigation zu machen und dann hinzufliegen und den zu packen, als sagen wir mal den Erdberuchtungs-Satelliten 15-mal im gleichen Schlauch fliegen zu lassen. Wobei das Schlauchfliegen und die Formationsfliegen ist schon spannend, aber es gibt halt einfach andere Satelliten, die fliegen ohne Treibstoff und so weiter, da ist man nur ganz reaktiv. Also es ist auch Forschung und Entwicklungsarbeit und es ist was Spannendes, an anderen Satelliten hinzufliegen und den einzufangen. Das ist auch ein zweites Interesse natürlich für ein Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum. Und dieses Anfliegen...
Also spannend im Sinne von einfach was Neues auszuprobieren.
Ja, das kann man sich vorstellen. Es ist spannender, irgendwie einen Bagger zu fahren und mit dem Bagger irgendwas zu machen als...
Aber bei spannend geht es ja jetzt nicht nur darum, dass jetzt hier die Leute mehr Spaß haben, es zu machen, sondern das bedeutet ja auch, man muss Neuland beschreiten, neue Technologien und Verfahren machen. Also der eigentliche wissenschaftliche Fortschrittsaspekt ist sozusagen auch interessant, weil das ja dann auch immer den Quernutzen hat, den eigentlichen.
Richtig. Ich meine, unsere Aufgabe ist ja, im DLR, in der Forschungseinrichtung, ist natürlich die Grenze weiter voranzutreiben, was machbar ist und nicht das Gängige. Also Kommunikationssatelliten im geostationären Orbit zu betreiben und in der Position zu halten, ist eine Aufgabe, die kommerzielle Satellitenbetreiber machen. Und zwar zwei Dutzend Satelliten, 24 Satelliten, 30 Satelliten.
Aber da muss nicht viel neu erfunden werden. Das ist wesentlich.
Kontrollraum, die automatisieren und wollen damit Geld verdienen. Da muss nicht Neues erfunden werden. Das ist Aufgabe der Industrie. Unsere Aufgabe ist es, die Grenzen neu auszustecken und mit den Mitteln des Steuerzahlers neue Techniken zu entwickeln, die man später mal braucht, die dann natürlich auch dem kommerziellen Aspekt helfen.
Weil man vielleicht in 30 Jahren irgendwann einen voll kommerziellen Betrieb hat. Abschlepp-Service hat, genau. Wir haben da hier noch irgendwie einen Satelliten rumhängen, der taumelt ein bisschen, den holen wir mal besser. Dann klickt man dann auf der Webseite, sagt hier, den hätte ich gern. Launch.
Aber das ist jetzt zu kompliziert, dass da gibt es noch keinen, die kommerziellen Betreiber warten da noch ab, bis halt ein F&E-Institut den Weg erstmal bereitet hat, bis Forschung und Entwicklung soweit ist.
Und an der Stelle erfüllt dann sozusagen das DLR ja auch eigentlich seine Kernaufgabe, die Bereiche abzustecken, wo heute noch hohes Risiko ist, dafür Lösungen zu finden, um die Sache dann eben auch urbar zu machen.
Und um diese Raumfahrt-reportlichen Missionen vorzubereiten, haben wir eben, ich habe es vorher schon mal erwähnt, sogenannte EPOS-Halle, European Proximity Operation Simulator, gebaut. Das ist eine Halle mit Robotern, ein Roboter auf einer Schiene von 25 Metern. Da kann man den Anflug eines Satelliten an einen anderen testen. Das sind große Industrieroboter, die Satellitenmodelle bis zu 200 Kilogramm schwere Modelle aufnehmen können, also Engineering-Modelle und die ganze Sensorik. Und dort kann man eben den Anflug von einem Servicing-Satelliten an einem Zielsatelliten testen. Den Zielsatelliten kann ich mit dem anderen Roboter ins Taumeln versetzen und dann fliege ich an mit meinen Sensoren, mit meinen Kameras oder mit meinem Leader, was auch immer ich habe, kann die, nicht nur die Sensorik, sondern die Algorithmen auch testen, die quasi aus den Kameras, Stereokameras den Abstand bestimmen zum Beispiel und kann dann die ganze Regelschleife des Anflugs testen, bis er zu einer Parkposition kommt, von wo aus man dann den Zielsatelliten greifen kann.
Ist die Halle schon voll in Betrieb?
Die Halle ist in Betrieb, ja.
Das heißt, das wird schon getan?
Das wird getan und wir haben nicht nur die Anflugnavigation dort implementiert, sondern auch eine Kontaktdynamik. Das heißt, es gibt Kraftmomentensensoren, die quasi bei einem Zugriff oder bei einem Docking auch messen, wie die Kraft ist beim Andocken, bei Kontakt, sodass man auch simulieren kann einen fehlgeschlagenen Kontakt. Das heißt, man ist ein paar Zentimeter daneben und dann muss man natürlich in der Simulation schauen, was macht man dann? Ist der Satellit, ist der Operator, ist der Algorithmus in der Lage, wieder beim Zurücktaumeln wieder Neuanlauf zu starten und den Satelliten dann zu greifen? Das alles wollen wir testen in verschiedenen einzelnen Stufen und am Schluss wollen wir einen integrierten Systemtest haben. Das heißt, wir haben den Zielsatelliten auf einem Roboter, wir haben den Service-Satellit auf einem anderen Roboter, wir haben die kompletten Sensorik dran und wir haben die Kommunikationsarchitektur mit ihrem Zeitverzögerung und dem Jitter, also der Schwankung der Zeitverzögerung mitimplementiert und haben die Kollegen dann im Kontrollraum sitzen, die quasi diesen Anflug dann steuern und so, dass wir erstmal am Boden alles simulieren und steuern können. Das ist der Vorteil von so einer Testanlage, die direkt im Kontrollzentrum implementiert ist.
Das ist jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, Schwerelosigkeit auch gar nicht erforderlich, so sehr erforderlich, weil die werden halt dann sozusagen auf gleicher Höhe gehalten, die Bahn einzunehmen.
Die wird simuliert. Doch, die Schwerelosigkeit ist ein Thema. Die wird in der Testanlage simuliert. Es wird also auch die richtige Bahn und die Zustände im Orbit simuliert.
Also simuliert durch die Roboter?
Durch die Roboter. Die halten natürlich die Struktur der Satelliten. Und beim Docken habe ich ja kleine Kräfte, die im Weltraum ein Zurücktaumeln quasi auslösen können und das muss ich dann durch die Software oder die Testanlage simulieren können.
Das heißt, die Roboter halten einfach diese Objekte einfach an der Stelle, wo sie sein müssten, wäre alles schwerelos und natürlich parallel auch noch irgendwie…
Nicht nur halten, sondern lassen die driften, als wäre alles schwerelos. Im Weltraum bleibt ja nichts an seiner Stelle. Wenn ich quasi örtlich versetzt bin, zum Beispiel wenn ich zehn Meter höher als die Raumstation bin, fängt der Astronaut oder was auch immer da ist, zehn Meter höher als die Raumstation, fängt an zu driften. Nach einem Orbit ist eine Werkzeugtasche, die ein Astronaut da liegen gelassen hat. Diese Werkzeugtasche ist nach einem Orbit um 370 Meter in Längsrichtung weitergewandert.
Aber wenn da jetzt so ein Roboter… Ich meine, was man nicht simulieren kann, ist die Abwesenheit der Roboter. Also man muss die Dinger ja irgendwie festhalten. Also so beliebige Taumelbewegungen sind jetzt auch nicht simulierbar, sondern nur in einem bestimmten Rahmen.
Aber man hat sechs Freiheitsgrade natürlich an den Robotern und die Translationsfreiheitsgrade. Also das ist schon das Beste, was man so auch auf der Erde testen kann.
Und das ist dann sozusagen auch schon erfolgt. Also man kriegt die Dinger.
Wir machen Vortests und machen Tests der Sensoren. Nachdem aber bei der Deus-Mission sind wir momentan in der Phase B bis zum System-Reiteness-Review. Wir haben aber noch die Satelliten noch gar nicht gebaut. Also Satelliten-Design geht mit einer Phase C los und D bauen. Also es gibt noch gar keine Engineering-Modelle von den Satelliten, die dann das einfangen. Das heißt, das wird dann in einer späteren Phase dann getestet. Wir haben die Testanlage gebaut und haben einzelne Komponenten bereits getestet.
Ist das noch sehr allgemein oder hat man sich jetzt auch schon bestimmte Objekte im Orbit ausgesucht, die man eigentlich so als erstes anfliegen wollen würde, wenn man weiß, dass die Technik funktioniert? Also orientiert man sich da jetzt schon an irgendwas, was so absehbar ist, was so in zehn Jahren ohnehin mal entsorgt werden müsste, aber noch nicht mit der entsprechenden Restenergie versorgt ist?
Ja, es gibt schon eine Liste, auch die ESA hat schon eine Studie dazu gemacht, welche Objekte sollte ich denn runterholen und an Nummer eins steht Envisat. Envisat im 800 Kilometer Orbit, acht Tonnen, hat noch Treibstoff, kann noch bis Ende dieses Jahrzehnts noch ausweichen, um Kollisionen zu vermeiden, hat aber eine sehr hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit, über den nächsten 100 Jahre, wenn es dann nicht mehr genug Treibstoff hat, um auszuweichen, hat es eine sehr hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit, dann tatsächlich getroffen zu werden.
Also er hat genug Treibstoff, um noch weiter betrieben zu werden, aber er hat nicht genug Treibstoff, um sich selber abstürzen zu lassen.
Richtig, ganz genau. Also der bräuchte weitaus mehr Treibstoff, um sich selbst nach unten zu bringen.
Und da er halt so groß ist, ist er natürlich das ideale Objekt für den ersten Test, weil er man ihn auch am einfachsten greifen könnte?
Nein, weil die Auswirkung am schlimmsten wäre. Wenn ich einen großen Satelliten habe von acht Tonnen, zeuge ich wesentlich mehr Trümmerstücke, als wenn ich einen 800-Kilogramm oder einen 80-Kilogramm-Satelliten irgendwo habe. Außerdem ist er in einer hohen Höhe. Satelliten, die in 400 Kilometer Höhe sind oder 500 Kilometer Höhe, haben noch so viel Restatmosphäre in dieser Höhe, dass sie sich selbst absenken. Ich habe vorher erwähnt, die internationale Raumstation sinkt permanent ab in 350 Kilometer Höhe. Der Höhenverlauf der Raumstation hat so ein Sägezahnprofil. Das liegt an der Restatmosphäre, deswegen muss die permanent angehoben werden. Vorteil ist aber bei der niedrigen Höhe die leichte Erreichbarkeit durch Speichschatteln usw. Es gibt auch Vorteile, aber sie muss permanent angehoben werden. Alte Satelliten, die in dieser Höhe rumfliegen, entsorgen sich relativ zügig von selbst nach unten.
Aber bei 800 Kilometern ist von der Restatmosphäre nicht mehr so viel zu merken. Und die würden einfach immer weiter fliegen.
Die fliegen über hunderte von Jahren noch in dieser Höhe und entsorgen sich nicht von selbst. Das ist das Problem. Es gibt ja den sogenannten European Code of Conduct für Space Debris, den die ESA mal vorgeschlagen hat. Da sagt man als Faustformel oder als Vorschlag, weil er noch nicht unterzeichnet ist, weil man sagt, alle Satelliten, alle Objekte, die man ausbringt im niedrigen Erdorbit, und der wird definiert von 200 Kilometer bis 2000 Kilometer Höhe, die sollen innerhalb von 25 Jahren nach Ende des Missionsbetriebes aus diesem Bereich entzockt werden, also nach unten und in der Erdbeer-Atmosphäre verglühen.
Also 25 Jahre nach Missionsende?
Nach Missionsende. Und so wie ich das überblicken kann, halten sich moderne, zukünftige Missionen schon an diese Vorgabe weitgehend. Aber die alten Missionen, die man vor zehn Jahren aufgeschossen hat oder entwickelt hat, die haben diesen Aser-Coddorff-Kontakt noch nicht.
25 Jahre klingt natürlich ganz schön viel. Aber es ist so ein Kompromiss, aus wie viel Energie man jetzt wirklich opfern muss, um das Ding runterzubringen.
Ja.
Lieber man weiß, dass er irgendwann auch mal wirklich unten ist, als dass er da ewig kreist.
Es geht halt um eine langfristige Zunahme der Dichte. Also wenn das in 25 Jahren unten ist, und die Trümmer-Teile sind ja dann auch unten, dann reinigt sich der Orbit selbst, also so 400 Kilometer Orbit oder sowas, die reinigen sich dann selbst. Aber gerade diese 800 Kilometer Orbit, die reinigen sich nicht und das ist dann hunderte von Jahren. Und man denkt halt auch an die langfristige Entwicklung dabei jetzt.
Verstehe ich das jetzt richtig, dass jetzt gerade dieser spezifische Robotikbereich eine besondere Bedeutung hat oder ist das jetzt tatsächlich auch so das zentrale Ding, was hier vorangetrieben wird aus dem Space-Operation-Center heraus oder gibt es noch andere zukünftige Ideen, die mit ähnlicher Energie vorangetrieben werden?
Also der Raumfahrt-Robotische Bereich hat schon eine besondere Bedeutung. Erstens mal, weil es eine Notwendigkeit gibt, zu reagieren auf den zunehmenden Weltraummüll und die Lösung, auf diesen zunehmenden Weltraummüll zu reagieren, irgendwas in jedem Fall mit der Robotik zu tun hat und mit der Anflugnavigation. Also man muss, um irgendein Objekt runterzuholen, egal wie man es macht, in jedem Fall hinfliegen können und irgendwas an dem anbringen kann.
Und trifft von daher auch den Kernbereich des Instituts.
Das hat in dem Sinne besondere Bedeutung für den Raumflugbetrieb und die Forschung im Raumflugbetrieb. Wir haben natürlich einen weiteren Schwerpunkt, den ich auf jeden Fall nennen sollte, oder den haben wir vorher auch schon angesprochen, das ist die robotische Exploration. Das ist ein Missionsbetrieb, der in Köln stattfindet, im Länderkontrollzentrum, der dann die Landung des Länders viele, der mit der Rosetta-Mission mitfliegt, steuern soll im Jahr 2014 und 2015. Also 2014 wird die Sonde Rosetta ankommen bei einem Kometen und der Betrieb wird noch im Jahr 2015 stattfinden. Von daher haben wir Expertise und Know-how im Bereich Kometen, Asteroiden und kleine Körper und Landung auf diesen Objekten. Diese Expertise wollen wir natürlich auch noch in Zukunft ausbauen. Deswegen sind wir momentan dabei, uns an verschiedenen internationalen Missionen zu beteiligen. Ein Beispiel ist die Hayabusa 2-Mission, die japanische Mission zu einem Asteroiden, die als Nachfolgemission zu Hayabusa 1, die ja sehr erfolgreich war, trotz etlicher Probleme, konnten die Japaner dann noch mikroskopische Körner von einem Kometen mit auf die Erde zurückbringen. Und das soll eine zweite Mission dann stattfinden, im Jahr 2018, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Und da haben wir die einmalige Gelegenheit, einen Lander auf dieser Sonde unterzubringen, einen zwar kleinen Lander, der ist Mascot genannt. Und da unterstützen wir jetzt das DLR und die Japaner dabei, diese Mascot-Mission auf Hayabusa 2 vorzubereiten.
Ja, also mal wirklich Proben von Asteroiden zurückzubringen, ist ja eine sehr gefragte Tätigkeit so in der Planetenforschung, wo man natürlich auf solche Samples mit spitzigen Händen wartet, um dort die Forschung weiter voranzubringen. Ja, das ergänzt sich natürlich auch schön. Wird denn, also das heißt, der Rosetta-Lander-Philae wird dann von Köln aus auch konkret gesteuert.
Ja, richtig.
Ja, das ist auch ein sehr spannendes Projekt. Ich erinnere mich jetzt gerade noch an die Details aus dem Gespräch mit Gerhard Schweben. Also kann ich auch jedem nur empfehlen, da nochmal reinzuhören. Ja, Florian, haben wir denn die wichtigsten Dinge erwähnt?
Die ganze Bandbreite durchgesprochen, ja. Würde mal sagen, was das Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum ist, das Deutsche Raumfahrt-Kontrollzentrum. Mit dem Missionsbetrieb haben wir, denke ich, mal die ganzen Themen abgedeckt.
Auf jeden Fall sehr viel vielfältiger noch, als der Name allein jetzt so vermuten lassen würde. Ich finde besonders einfach diesen Bereich der zukünftigen Entwicklung sehr interessant. Also man merkt, dass dann auch so dieser auf den ersten Blick von Routine durchweigte Betrieb ja einfach auch so der Nährboden ist für zukünftige Raumfahrt-Ideen an sich, die man dann auch wiederum in andere Institute hineintragen kann und auch in andere Organisationen. Ja, dann würde ich sagen, machen wir hier mal den Kasten zu. Ich sage vielen Dank, Florian Selmeier, für die Ausführungen hier zum GSOC. Und natürlich auch vielen Dank hier an alle Zuhörer. Das war es, die 36. Ausgabe von Raumzeit und es wird nicht die letzte bleiben. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.